ALL -- ALMOST ALL OF RUSSIAN
ADVANCES IN UKRAINE REMAIN
STALLED, ACCORDING TO THAT
OFFICIAL.
>> NO, I THINK RUSSIA IS
STRATEGICALLY AND OPERATIONALLY
IS IN TROUBLE IN THIS SPECIAL
OPERATIONS THEY CALL IT.
THEY HAVEN'T MADE THE SPEED OF
MOVEMENT, THEY HAVEN'T ACHIEVED
THEIR OBJECTIVES.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE SUSTAIN
ABILITY TO KEEP PUSHING WITHOUT
THESE OPERATIONAL PAUSES.
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR SOMETHING.
MAYBE CHINESE SUPPORT.
MAYBE THE USE OF A CHEMICAL
WEAPON OR MAYBE SOME KIND OF
DIPLOMATIC COVER THAT GIVES THEM
AN OPPORTUNITY TO REORGANIZE AND
DO SOMETHING LATER.
SO THEY'RE IN TROUBLE.
TACTICALLY, THIS BATTLE WILL BE
DECIDED AND OPERATIONALLY BY THE
AMOUNT OF MUNITIONS, STINGERS,
JAVELINS AND OTHER THINGS THAT
WE CAN HELP THE UKRAINIANS
ACQUIRE.
THEY NEED SUPPORT.
AND THEY NEED IS VERY BADLY.
THE BATTLE FOR UKRAINE IS
HANGING IN THE BALANCE REALLY.
IF WE COULD GET ENOUGH IN THERE,
THEY'RE PUSH THE RUSSIANS OUT.
IT WILL BE A TREMENDOUS WIN FOR
THE WEST AND IT WILL BE A REAL
FAILURE FOR PUTIN IF WE CAN'T
GET IT IN THERE, THIS SLOW GRIND
COULD CONTINUE AND YOU'LL SEE
MORE MARIUPOLS.
>> SHAWN, WHAT ABOUT THAT
REQUEST FOR MILITARY AND
ECONOMIC ASSISTANCE FROM CHINA.
SO THE KREMLIN IS ASKING KLINE
FOR HELP.
IS THAT IN CHINA'S BEST
INTEREST?
ARE THEY GOING TO DO THAT?
>> WELL, YOU IT IS A GOOD POINT.
I THINK AT THE OUTSET, WE ALL
BELIEVE THAT RUSSIA WOULD HAVE A
MUCH EASIER TIME OVERWHELMING
THE UKRAINIAN FORCES AN THEY
SENT A MESSAGE THEY'RE GOING TO
STAND AND FIGHT AND THEY'VE DONE
SO BRAVELY AND SO I THINK WHAT
IS HAPPENING HERE IS THE
COMBINATION OF THE CRIPPLING
SANCTIONS AN THE UKRAINIANS
RESILIENCE HAS PUT PUTIN IN A
DESPERATE SITUATION.
HE'S RUNNING OUT OF RESOURCES
AND ISOLATE AND UP AGAINST A
WALL AND I'M NOT SURPRISED THAT
HE'S REACHING OUT TO CHINA.
BUT TO YOUR QUESTION, I DON'T
THINK IT IS IN CHINA'S INTEREST
TO GO BEYOND WHAT THEY'VE
ALREADY BEEN DOING AND SO FAR
THEY ARE AMPLIFYING RUSSIA'S
MISINFORMATION.
I THINK THAT THEY UNDERSTAND
THAT THAT IS PROBABLY AS FAR AS
THEY CAN GO BECAUSE IF THEY WERE
TO HELP RUSSIA DIPLOMATICALLY OR
RUSSIA ECONOMICALLY OR
MILITARILY, THE COST THAT THEY
WOULD PAY IN TERMS OF THEIR OWN
ECONOMY WOULD SIMPLY DOO GREAT.
SO I THINK THAT THAT IS A
CONVERSATION THAT WILL SORT OF
HAPPEN, BUT IT WILL FALL AWAY
BECAUSE CHINA IS NOT GOING TO DO
ANYTHING THAT IS NOT IN CHINA'S
BEST INTEREST.
>> GENERAL, ON THE ATTACK ON
THIS MILITARY BASE JUST WEST OF
LVIV ON SUNDAY, A DOZEN MILES OR
SO FROM THE POLISH BORDER.
OF COURSE POLAND BEING A NATO
MEMBER.
THIS WASN'T A HOSPITAL, IT
WASN'T A SCHOOL, IT WASN'T A
GROCERY STORE AS WE'VE SEEN IN
SOME OF THE CENTERS OF THE CITY.
THIS IS A MILITARY BASE.
BUT DO YOU SEE THAT PRIMARILY AS
A PROVOCATION, OF TRYING TO
PROVOKE POLAND AND NATO?
>> NO, I SEE IT AS A DEFENSIVE
MOVE BY THE RUSSIANS.
KNOWING THEY'RE IN TROUBLE
BECAUSE THIS BASE APPARENTLY WAS
BEING USED TO FUNNEL IN
INTERNATIONAL PERSONNEL.
AND SO THEY KILLED A NUMBER OF
THESE PEOPLE.
AND IT IS AN EFFORT TO PREVENT
THEM BEING REINFORCED FROM
OUTSIDE ADDITIONAL PEOPLE.
SO I'M SURE THE UKRAINIANS HAVE
TAKEN MEASURES FOR THAT.
AND THE RUSSIANS MONITORED AND
PICKED IT UP AND THEY STRUCK.
AND I THINK IT WAS COINCIDENTAL
DUE TO ITS LOCATION BUT ON THE
THE OTHER HAND, THE RUSSIANS ARE
HAPPY TO TRY TO INTIMIDATE NATO
AND KEEP NATO OFF BALANCE AND
DEFENSIVE.
SO IN THAT RESPECT, IT WASN'T A
MISTAKE.
BUT THAT WASN'T THE PRIMARY
PURPOSE OF THE STRIKE.
IN MY VIEW.
>> SEAN, WE HAVE HEARD THE
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER JAKE
SULLIVAN BEGIN TO TALK ABOUT THE
WORST CASE SCENARIO THAT
EVERYBODY IS RELUCTANT TO TALK
ABOUT WHICH IS A NUCLEAR
CONFRONTATION.
SO LET ME JUST PLAY FOR YOU WHAT
HE SAID YESTERDAY.
>> THE ESCALATION RISK WITH A
NUCLEAR POWER IS SEVERE.
AND IT IS A DIFFERENT KIND OF
CONFLICT THAN OTHER CONFLICTS
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE SEEN
OVER THE YEARS.
AS THINGS STAND TODAY, THE
UNITED STATES HAS NOT ADJUSTED
OUR NUCLEAR POSTURE.
BUT IT IS SOMETHING THAT WE
MONITOR DAY BY DAY, HOUR-BY-HOUR
BECAUSE IT IS A PARAMOUNT
PRIORITY TO THE PRESIDENT.
>> WHAT HAPPENS IF VLADIMIR
PUTIN GOES NUCLEAR?
>> WELL, I THINK IF THAT
HAPPENS, THEN IT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE ALL NEED TO BE CONCERNED
ABOUT.
LOOK, THERE IS NO DOUBT HERE
THAT VLADIMIR PUTIN'S EGO HAS
BEEN BRUISED.
THE DISINFORMATION WAR HAS NOT
GONE AS HE ANTICIPATED.
CERTAINLY HE'S NOT DOING AS WELL
MILITARILY AS HE ANTICIPATE AND
AS THIS GRINDS ON AN HE
CONTINUES TO HAVE FAILURES, SOME
OF THE FAILURES THAT GENERAL
CLARK TALKED ABOUT, HIS
DESPERATION, IT IS GOING TO BE
AMPLIFIED.
AND SO WHAT WE HAVE TO DO IS
MAKE SURE THAT BOTH HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES, BUT ALSO ACROSS
THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY,
THAT WE LAY OUT CLEAR AND
CONCLUSIVE GUIDELINES FOR WHAT
MEANS IF VLADIMIR PUTIN CROSSES
THAT RED LINE.
AND TO BE REALLY CLEAR, IT IS
NOT JUST ABOUT WHAT THE UNITED
STATES DOES.
WE NEED TO COME TOGETHER WITH
THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY AND
SPEAK IN ONE VOICE AND BE VERY
CLEAR THAT THERE WILL BE A QUICK
AND SWIFT REACTION SHOULD
VLADIMIR PUTIN MOVE FORWARD AND
WE NEED TO SEND THAT MESSAGE
RIGHT NOW SO THAT HE'S
DISCOURAGED IN EVERY POSSIBLE
WAY.
BUT AS W